I have Nikolas beat with reason TV and
today I'm very happy to be talking with
Jerome to Chile author most recently of
gallo be thy name the inside story of
how a secretive but well-connected
family rose to dominate the u.s. wine
market we're talking about the Gallo
brothers the gala family right the Gallo
wine family started Ernest and Giulio of
the the two patriarchs you might say of
that clan their parents started before
prohibition making wine in California
they had an uncle who was known as the
Al Capone of the west coast his name was
Mike Gallo they deny it
Ernest and I dug up into his till he
died about a year and a half two years
ago but they were running a wine during
Prohibition to the Capone mob I think
they were doing a public service
supplying the public with well if
nothing else there were a lot of masses
that needed sacramental wines and the
prohibition sacramental wine was exempt
this book and what I think is
fascinating about it is that it's it's a
social history pegged to a family an
immigrant family a family an Italian
family with roots elsewhere and you're
talking about a product that has come in
the past fifty years of the past sixty
years to really kind of define and
exemplify a very large shift in American
sensibilities where we went from maybe
having jug wine once in a while at a
beatnik poetry reading to now we love
really rarified great tasting wines from
all over the world this is a story of
immigration of Commerce of technological
innovation of globalization what was the
wine world like before prohibition in
America there was a palate for wine in
the United States before prohibition
back in the 1890s people dressed up to
go out they put on suits and ties and
fedoras and and they drank good wine
we've enjoyed wine in this country since
the days of Thomas Jefferson we try to
grow wine in Virginia and imported wine
from Italy in France
prohibition killed the American palate
for wine it was illegal so it was easier
to make beer and gin and you bathtub so
this became a beer and whiskey drinking
country it took a long time to develop
that palate again and the gallows of
course came from Italy where wine was an
everyday thing good wine was an everyday
affair they they wouldn't even think of
consuming a meal without having a glass
of wine to go with it but unfortunately
as they tried to make good wine right
after prohibition ended in 1933 but
there was resistance out there they
couldn't sell it
giulio in particular was the winemaker
Ernest was the tough guy in the
marketing agent good salesman so what do
they do to get a niche into the market
they they made a Thunderbird all the
garbage
slok out there big gallons of and
Thunderbird Thunderbird was a sweet
fortified wine yes it was the sweet wine
tasted more like port but they actually
they put lemon in it to cut back on the
sweetness so I mean they're I mean they
didn't want to make this wine but they
knew how to serve a market you they did
they also made ripple is that right
ripple was another one of their Boone's
Farm Tom Apple wines they had all kinds
of by the way we'd have to stop because
I'm having flashbacks to my adolescence
now yeah well but I mean so the Gallo
brothers in a weird way are like you
know they're the starter family of
people now who drink good wine some of
which is made by the Gallo family right
some of which is made by the Gallo
family today the the problem for the
gallows is that people don't trust the
Gallo label so when they as the youngest
generation right now Gina and Matt Gallo
the grandchildren of Giulio are really
making top-shelf wines at a low price
but people won't buy it because of the
Gallo label so what they've done to get
around that is they've bought up
high-end wineries like the martini Luis
martini Frye brothers they Bart good
labels from Chile and Argentina and
Italy and you won't see galas name on
them but if you see bottled or
in Modesto California that's a code name
for Gallo
I mean the gala zone Modesto California
what is the what's the large narrative
of the gala family saga what's what's
the gala family's tragedy or epic talk
well it's not just the biography it's
also a history a saga of American social
history and it's also a true crime story
the book actually starts with the murder
of earnest and Julio's parents in Fresno
California
the police covered it up but went down
you know father goes crazy kills his
wife and then shoots himself of the
circumstantial evidence has convinced me
that it was a mob hit that they owed
money to the wrong people
some members of the Gallo family have
told me that so there's the true crime
element so from that and from the ashes
of Prohibition Ernest and Giulio come
along the first generation Americans and
they had the knowledge of winemaking
which they started they had a tough time
after prohibition because she had the
Great Depression but they competed with
the the likes of Mondavi and Sebastiani
these were established dams in
California winemaking and at some point
1012 years later they actually out
competed them they had competed them by
making Thunderbird and by making ripple
and later on Boone's Farm and Bartles
and Jaymes and all the things that
Americans wanted to drink well this glop
and at that point Giulio insisted that
let's get into the fine wine field and
they tried and tried and have had a lot
of time trouble overcoming that stigma
of their early years the new generation
as I mentioned has had a more success in
doing it but not as great a success in
marketing it there's still a resistance
against that but they've also used the
political system to further their ends
they were giving a lot of money to the
Clinton campaign and they got favorable
tract tax treatment Bob Dole a
Republican
call that the Gallo tax amendment so
they started giving a lot of money to
Bob Dole they actually became his number
one a political campaign contributors
after that Dole shut his mouth and went
along for their for the ride they tried
to keep Chilean wines and the foreign
wines out of the United States they
succeeded for a couple of years but then
finally the floodgates open and all the
really good ones at low-cost point
started coming in from Australia and
elsewhere and so the gallows was smart
enough to respond by by buying and
establishing footholds in foreign
markets to the point where they
controlled maybe 30 labels you don't
know what's even Gallo
so this is I mean their their family
saga is a kind of microcosm or a slice
of American life and not not like the
Godfather and as a half of
italian-american I feel like I can make
you know unsavory Italian references but
I mean but there's a crime at the
beginning of a dynasty which then you
know goes through tough times becomes
entrepreneurial not just in a business
sense but also in a political sense and
we get to a point where we are in
America where we are all rich or we were
all more well-connected and we are all
more discriminating in our tastes for
virtually everything right I look at it
as a great American success story I I
grew up in a in the Bronx and a
working-class neighborhood my father was
a cab driver my mother's father owned a
bar and a restaurant and the story of
people who've come from even more
poverty-stricken backgrounds than that
and gone on to achieve a nogales case
billions has always been fascinating to
me that people can pull themselves up
the system allows that we have a lot of
complaints about the government and
restraints on freedom and that's all
true but it's it's still possible and it
always has been to lift yourself out of
the ghettos and go on and achieve great
wealth and great fame and look at Gallo
and I think previous writers have failed
to capture him people love to hate
Ernest L he was a thug he was a tough
guy
but the man was also a genius and I
think a lot of people who love to hate
earnest Gallio a Gallo mr. genius
component there you don't achieve what
he achieved without having a great sense
of the marketplace of being a visionary
and where cultural trends are heading
and positioning yourself and out
competing some major competition along
the way so there was a combination here
of thug tough-guy and also genius and
what I try to do in this book is capture
both sides of this man well I want to
thank drove to Chile for talking to
recent TV about his new book Gallo be
thy name a rich social history of a
family business that's right at the that
tells a lot about America over the past
hundred years thanks Jerry thank you
you